ryan giggs accepts he's known around the
world for two things his abilities as a
footballer and his inability to remain
faithful to his partners he admitted to
the jury that that reputation for
infidelity was justified and that he
lied to the women he was in
relationships with about being
unfaithful but to the allegation that he
assaulted his then girlfriend kate
greville he said he'd never physically
assaulted any woman he also denied that
he'd taken advantage or tried to
manipulate her
under questioning from defense counsel
chris daw mr giggs was asked have you
ever set out to control or coerce a
woman in any way or in the ways alleged
by miss gravel no he replied
mr door went on did you make kate
greville a slave to your every need and
demand as she described i did not mr
giggs replied he was asked about an
incident in dubai in february of 2017
when it's alleged he threw miss greville
naked from a hotel room that he told the
jury didn't happen
they'd rowed he said and he'd asked her
to leave but things had calmed down and
they spent the night together it was the
jury was told part of a pattern of ups
and downs in their relationship it
wasn't unusual mr giggs said but i
wouldn't say it was regular
mr giggs admitted he enjoyed the
attention he received from women as a
result of his football fame in lying to
his wife about his affairs including
with miss greville he accepted that in
the words of his counsel he wanted to
have his cake and eat it mr giggs is
alleged to have head-butted miss
greville at the home they shared in
november 2020. the court heard a
statement he gave to police in which he
said there may have been contact in a
scuffle but that there was no intent
he was asked about an email with an
attachment labeled blackmail that he
said was a joke he admitted their
behavior was immature but that it was
his understanding that miss greville
wanted him to fight for their
relationship his evidence continues greg
milam sky news manchester